hello everyone and welcome to the 1991
Linares series featuring Vasiliy even
the 1991 Linares tournament was a very
strong tournament that featured the 14
of the strongest players in the world
such as world champion Garry Kasparov
Anatoly Karpov Viswanathan Anand de gata
Kamsky I used to put Belyaev ski-doo boy
which a lot of strong players well
anyway I already did a video and on the
first game of this tournament Yvan
Chuck's first game in round 1 that's the
game against world champion Garry
Kasparov and well Gary at the time this
game was played it was rated 2800 so he
was the only player in the world with
such a rating and Anatoly Karpov who was
the second rated had a rating of 20 725
so there was a 75 point the point
difference lastly one Chuck was the
fourth favorite well if you consider
rating he was twenty-six hundred and
ninety-five so more than 100 points
below world champion Garry Kasparov but
nevertheless you're welcome to check out
that game if you haven't you can check
it out on my channel I will also put a
link in the description below the game
round one event versus Kasparov that's
even Chuck's immortal game so maybe you
would prefer to watch that one before
you see this one this is event versus
Karpov this is round five of the Linares
in 1991 tournament and even chuck has
invented has the white pieces against
the former world champion a man Chuck
goes d4 we have Knight to f6 c4 e6
Knight to c3 and Bishop to b4 Karpov
goes for the nimzo-indian III Karpov
castles Bishop to d3 d5 Knight to f3 and
c5 Karpov does what he often does and
well you'll see what it is a bunch of
castles and Karpov plays see chapter 74
we have each captures on d4 now D
captures on c4
Bishop captures on c4 and b6 Karpov is
preparing to develop his light square
Bishop on this beautiful diagonal
what else he did well he created and
isolated the d4 pawn which will well
he'll try to make this pawn a target for
the rest of the game this is something
harp over well often does and it will be
event you duty to make this well-born
seem like a like a like a strength
rather than a weakness but we'll see
event replace Bishop to g5 pinning the
night
Bishop to b7 rook the c1 developing the
rook Knight to c6 and now a3 and carpo
plays Bishop to e7 of course you don't
want to capture on c3 Bishop captures on
c3 and B captures on c3 this would only
strengthen this d4 pawn and now there is
no dark square bishop to to contest this
dark square Bishop of event rooks and g5
so instead after a three
Karpov plays the Bishop to e7 we have
Queen to d3 and well this is well
probably the first moment in the game
where Karpov doesn't really play well
it's not a bad move but it's an
inaccuracy for example a better move
than what he played would be h6 and then
depending on where this Bishop goes for
example either he will capture or he
will play something like Bishop to f4
and then well after Bishop to d6 a
couple will be able to exchange some
pieces and well go faster into the
endgame but after Queen to d3
Karpov played a Knight to d5 now opening
up an attack on this g5 Bishop probably
would the idea that if well if Bishop
captures on e7 is played Karpov can
always recapture with the night and all
is well but the problem after this
Knight to d5 move is that if I played
Bishop captures on d5 eventually gives
up the bishop pair but now Bishop
captures for example on g5
well I wouldn't result in something
carpet would be interested to play for
example Knight captures in g5 now we
want you his threatening checkmate on
age 7 and after Queen captures on g5 you
want to catch this in between move f4
with an attack on the Queen and after
Queen to e7 and Bishop to e4
well there is a lot of pressure on the
kingside here and it well of course rook
f1 rook h3 is coming this would be this
wouldn't be something Harper would enjoy
he would have to push f5 and weaken his
King side position and also he would
create a weak pawn here on e6 so instead
after this Bishop captures on d5 by a
von Schuch
Karpov played in capture Sun d5 now he
created a weak pawn of his own a weak
isolated pawn but well he does he does
think that this will give him a better
game so Bishop captures only 7 by van
choke Knight characters and e7 and rook
to e1 and all of the Avengers pieces are
developed both rocks are on open files
and what Casper Karpov still has to do
this
so he goes rotate rotate the CA
developing the rook and well what to
play now this night is pretty badly
placed on e7 so Karpov is definitely
going to look to improve it he can't
really go to f5 the queen is protecting
f5 and well he'll probably go to g6 or
to c6 so if I'd replace H for his idea
is to push h5 to further limit to this
Knights movement we have h6 by by Karpov
not allowing any Knight g5 ideas so h6
and the event she pushes h5 now further
constricting this Knights options we had
rook to c7 nice to b5 would attempt on
the rook now rook captures on c1 rook
captures in c1 and Bishop to a6 not
pinning this night you want to place a 4
we have Bishop captures only for Queen
captures an a4 and Knight to f5 now the
night is well in in the game and well
this is a pretty good square for the
knight so g3 my man Chuck not allowing
this night to jump to h4 to exchange
even more pieces so g3 is played Knight
back to e7 as the knight that doesn't
really have any any more future and a5
nice to e5 now now why vine took a noun
event who has a beautiful night here on
e5 and well since Knight to g6
isn't really possible Knight to c6 is
definitely impossible there's really no
way to dislodge this night for me five
other than by pushing f6 and well Karpov
is still a bit reluctant to do this so
Queen to d6 we have Queen to a6 Avant
you wants to gobble up this a 7-point
it's a very juicy pawn but again he gets
nice to f5 by Karpov now Karpov says
okay grab the a 7-point I'm gonna grab
the d4 pawn which of course the central
pawn is a bit more important it's
creating an outpost for that knight on
d5 so pin to d3 defending d4 we have
Knight back to e7
and Queen to f3 now and well here
Karpov really doesn't like that knight
on e5 so he still doesn't want to go for
f6 he plays a5 first we have King to g2
even shook improves the position of the
King and well if if the position
suddenly goes into the endgame just the
his King will be closer to jump into the
game and okay now Karpov does play f6 as
there is really nothing better here we
have nice to d3 probably now going for
ideas like Knight f4 and Knight to g6 or
maybe Knights to e6 if the rook comes to
e1 or the Queen goes to e3 well it all
depends on what Karpov plays rook the c8
Karpov offers the exchange of rooks and
this is well this is where things get
interesting exchanging the rook well the
position will still favour will be
favorable to white but even Chuck
doesn't go for the rook exchange he
plays rook to e1 getting rook now on the
other open file and Karpov immediately
goes for that pawn on d4 rook to c4 and
well here Avenger would probably I do
have to mention that both players were
extremely low on time here for example
with a move like Queen to e3 this
defense d4 and also attacks this night
on e7 and this would be a pretty good
chance for Karpov to to really blunder
for example Knight to f5 and well this
comes with
upon the Queen but black is lost for
example 28 check and if you play King to
h7 you get Queen g6 check and wow this
is completely over after for example
King g8 you get to roki eight check you
lose the Queen this is completely over
and after this Queen - eh check if you
play something like Queen - f8 well this
is isn't really any better you get Queen
to e6 with check and now after Queen f7
you grab the night this is game over so
after this rook to c4 move after this
rook to c4 move if I didn't play Queen
to e3 he played Knight to f4 and of
course Karpov grabbed the pawn I mean
it's a free pawn and you might get the
idea that he want to play Knight to
afford to play a move like rook to e6
but the problem is after Queen to d7 and
rook to b6 well this would be this would
still be okay for black and it's it's
well I don't know if this is something
if I was going for but he didn't play
this after this rookie catcher sandy for
if I didn't play rook to e6 rather he
played Knight to g6 and this is well
he's attacking this night and he's seven
twice now with the knight and rook and
Karpov captures the knight I mean I mean
what is a bunch of thinking here Knight
captures pawn captures and well black is
upon up and well Kirk eventually does
have a double G pawn but he's already
threatening rook to e8 winning the Queen
so this must be stopped corporate police
came to f8 and the one took jumps with
Queen to h5 Queen to a5 sorry now
threatening Quinta CA twit checkmate so
again this has to be stopped Karpov
plays rook to c4 and well this is this
is a very nice moment in the game
probably most of us would play rook to
e6 with the idea that after the Queen
moves well you either pick up the b6
pawn or maybe you do have some ideas of
sacrificing the rook
f6 and pushing g7 but the problem is
after Queen to d8 none of this really
works
the queen is protecting the d5 pawn so
mean to d5 capturing is impossible the
Queen is protecting the b6 pawn and the
Queen is protecting this f6 pawn from
eventual recaptures and f6 ideas so if I
should probably saw that this rook to e6
wasn't really working so instead after
rook captures on c4 event took place
what I consider to be anyone should move
he played g4 and what's the idea behind
g4 I really don't know I mean probably
he probably wanted to give Karpov a
chance to make a mistake or maybe if
carpel would somehow attack his queen
with his queen that he can
well sometimes recapture with G captures
on i-5 and create well a strong pawn on
d6 I have no idea but whatever the idea
behind divine troops g4 was completely
through carpel off of his game like I
said he will he really was in a time
trouble and here well carpet played
Queen to f4 he decided to go for this g4
pawn and thought that this would be
enough I mean he is up a pawn so why not
but the problem is here I don't really
know if Karpov resigned the game
immediately
I believe he resigned the game but he
was also extremely low on time because
here event occurs Queen captures on d5
and this is completely lost for Karpov
he mantra would be threatening Queen to
f7 checkmate and the problem is after
Queen captures and g4 would check and
King to f1 you can't grab this pawn if
you grab the pawn you lose you lose the
rook with Queen captures on c4 and if
you don't well what do you play here
still Queen Queen to f7 checkmate is the
threat if you try another check Queen to
h3 you get King to eat too and if you
try another check for example Queen g4
now you get King to d3 and now even
chokes King is attacking this rook
I mean the queen is attacking it as well
so the rook is attacked twice black is
losing a rook if he doesn't want to be
checkmated with a queen to f7 so after
this Queen to f4 move
I believe Karpov did resign but he was
in severe time trouble as well
probably when he played this weird two
Queen to f4 move but my favorite thing
is that eventually in this position
played g4 it's a such a manly move it's
it's Wow well I'm interested what are
your thoughts about this g4 move why was
it played so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to say
that a von Schuch 1 Linares 1991 with a
score of 13 and a half points that's six
win wins and seven rose and he wanted
what half a point lead a head of world
champion Garry Kasparov who only lost
one game in this tournament and that was
the game in round one against vastly von
Schuch the eventual immortal which you
are free to check out so yeah that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it as usual
you can check what this will be one
trips immortal right up there and the
other one will be one of my previous
videos thank y'all for watching and I
will see you soon